That ends the lesson.
I was about to say that ends
the lesson on Luke's flow.
That's pretty much true.
It's only a little bit of a lie because
we're going to see a little bit more
of this derivative motion stuff in the,
in the next lesson.
But basically what we did is we solved
for a different flow at every point
by assuming that a window over that
point had a particular flow everywhere.
Then we move the window a little bit,
and now we pretend that
in this new window, the flow might be
something different, even though those
windows overlap, which is a little
strange but, but that's how you do it.
So it's okay to have small
errors along the way like that.
But the idea, so there's a little
bit of a contradiction here, right?
In fact that contradiction
is in what I just said.
We assume that a window is all
moving the same way around a point,
and we assign that value to that point,
then we move the window a little bit and
we throw away that last thing,
and we say we're
going to assign it to the next point
even though those windows overlap.
You might say,
I want to carve the image up into
sort of coherently moving patches.
And so, there's two parts of that.
There's this notion of how
do I do the carving up.
And what do you mean
by coherently moving?
And what that means is you've
got a model for the motion
inside these regions, and the next
lesson will talk about motion models and
how we could find regions that behave
according to some motion model.